in 1895 the average argentinian was
roughly as rich as the average american
in 1995 the average american was three
and a half times richer than the average
argentinian
but why why did argentina decline so in
the final years of the 19th century
argentina was seen as a potential great
power
it had high levels of economic growth
mostly due to the export of meat and the
massive inflow of european and american
investment
argentina's government at this point
though was to put it mildly quite
corrupt
now this growth couldn't last forever
and sure enough it didn't and growth
rates slowed in the wake of world war
one
much of this was down to the fact that
the countries investing in argentina
were now broke
fortunately though in 1929 things got
much better for argentina and by much
better i mean worse because great
depression
now like most nations argentina did not
have a fun time during the great
depression and its primary export was
hit pretty hard but have no fear britain
argentina's primary export market was
there to help and signed a deal with the
argentinian government
in this britain was granted a monopoly
on selling coal to argentina and also
preferred trade status
and also british companies would be
allowed to effectively control the
argentinian meat market
now a country giving away control of its
primary export may seem like a bad idea
and that's because it is that said the
rulers of argentina didn't care because
this made them very rich
the economic collapse and slowdown in
the wake of the great depression meant
that your average argentinian began to
feel a lot poorer
this shockingly led to widespread
political discontent and extremism and a
lot of military coups in the following
decades
one man who rose to prominence as a
result of this instability was juan
peron who took office in 1946.
his primary goals were to remove british
influence in the economy to
industrialize the nation and to decrease
inequality
now to be fair to perron he did succeed
in his aims at first
in argentina had a five-year economic
boom however
this didn't last and perron's popularity
declined as economic woes returned to
argentina this was mostly due to the
fact that he nationalized everything
owned by foreigners which scared off
investors because nobody likes having
their stuff taken
perron was himself a victim of a
military coup and spent about 20 years
in exile and during this time argentina
never recovered
spending couldn't be brought under
control for several reasons
first social programmes and investment
were extremely popular with the people
second the government had to spend lots
of money on the military to maintain its
power and three
internationally the argentine peso was
seen as worth less and less which made
imports much more expensive
even when peron returned as president in
the 1970s he couldn't fix these issues
which led to massive levels of
polarization and of course
inflation and in the end his successor
his wife was overthrown in 1976 by
argentina's infamous military hunter
the hunter did three things it failed to
get spending under control it lost an
expensive war and then it promptly fell
apart
leaving the country in a worse shape
than it found it and further efforts to
change the peso switches between
interventionist and laissez-faire
economic policies and rampant corruption
meant that argentina saw a solid 50-year
period
of economic turmoil and it was because
of these reasons economic subservience
to another country decades of
out-of-control spending and periods of
immense political turmoil and
dictatorship that meant that argentina
would never get back to the growth of
the previous century
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly money maker
anthony beckett the pastry section danny
maloney
rob waterhouse moe aaron the white james
castaneda jordan longley
jerry lamdin marcus arsenal gustav swan
john bailey cooling castleman rasheed
ali
spinning three plates fielder oink oink
izzy david silverman maggie paxkowski
winston caywood spencer lightfoot robert
wetzel fortunate calf
lexi schwinn sky chappelle and marvin
casau
turns out militaries can't run economies